[Music]
hey shannon welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
so i am in analysis paralysis with some
special circumstances
um
during college i kind of had what i
refer to as a mental breakdown because i
don't know what else to call it but my
anxiety and depression got worse and
then covet happened and i started
getting agoraphobia so luckily i've been
able to talk to some professionals that
have helped me and i'm actually now able
to have a part-time job so i can start
making some money where'd it go
you're able to leave home
yes now i am um especially i i'm getting
thank you yeah i'm able to get a service
dog in september so that's really going
to help me too hey that's a that's a
hard one i i i know i keep interrupting
you i'm sorry but that's a hard one i
want to celebrate that with you is that
cool
thank you yes that's tough man
especially on the back end of kovid
getting out and yeah we weaponized each
other during that season and so good for
you i'm proud of you
okay sorry for interrupting you go ahead
go ahead
no you're good so i have since getting
the service dog i have a huge unexpected
cost and since i'm only able
to work part-time for now
i don't know how to come up with that
cost my parents
got like a huge bonus this past year so
they offered to pay for it in cash and
then just had me pay it later
but i didn't know like i don't know what
to do first i know i have the thousand
dollar emergency fund
but do i pay them back to get my debt
cleared because i don't have i won't
have any student debt
or
do i continue saving to rent somewhere
or have a house like i don't know yeah
there's okay so is the big expense that
you said at the beginning of this the
dog the service dog is that correct yeah
okay so how much is that
it's going to be sixteen thousand two
hundred sixteen thousand okay
what debt do you have right now shannon
um i have
just fifteen hundred dollars left from
my last class um this fall but i have
enough cash to pay for that ahead of
time okay so there's no
credit cards or car loans or anything
no i actually was introduced to you guys
before
i even started high school so i tried to
oh wow before that and then my parents
had saved up money for me so that's
awesome how old are you shannon
22 22. okay very cool okay are you at
home right now living at home
yes okay yeah and so you're looking to
move out kind of start your life
and
be an adult right that you're just yeah
you're ready to to leave the nest which
is awesome so do you have any do you
have any money saved
um after i graduate i get
money that my parents had set aside for
me so between
between like working before i got this
job and that i'll have like ten thousand
dollars right where i graduate great and
the service dog is coming in you said
september
yeah is that right okay
so you have about yeah
three months or so um
yeah to come up with six thousand
dollars how much are you making right
now
um right now i'm making 13.50 an hour
and i work like 25 hours a week so okay
okay so if i were you i would do
priority of what's the most important in
my life to
um
be self-sufficient right and this dog to
me is number one it's even before moving
out um
getting this dog in place because that
dog is really gonna be the thing that
i'm from what i'm hearing you and john
correct me if i'm wrong too that's going
to help you
really be able to to work more hours to
be able to live independently and and
really continue to live life the way you
want to as an adult is that correct
yeah it is okay and with your particular
response your particular phobia your
particular anxiety response
running out and getting your own place
and
immediately re-isolating yourself may be
tough right now does that make sense
yeah and that's how it kind of got worse
when i was in college because i had a
roommate but college was like two three
hours away from my family who i was
really close to
so it felt like i was isolating myself
so i would love to like rachel saying
i'd love you to do this in the right
order which sounds like i'm gonna delay
moving out from home for six months or
seven months and i'm gonna sit down with
mom and dad and we're gonna write this
down together so
they're on the same page i'm on the same
page we're all good and think of it less
like you're
this dog is not like a car right they're
not buying you a thing they are
participating in your
in really in your in your health right
they're helping with the think of it
like more of a medical payment than
they're buying you a new bicycle or
something okay
and so um we're going to
get
get this relationship with this dog and
those things are magical by the way i've
seen some really remarkable turnarounds
with folks i'm going to get really
comfortable with this dog and then i'm
going to in this season i'm going to
start i'm going to spread out my work
hours and i'm going to start
leaning into that anxious discomfort
okay
and your your counselor is probably
working with you on that is that right
yes definitely so we're going to we're
going to we're going to end up short
circuiting that
anxiety response we're going to keep
leaning into that and we're going to
have this dog and we're going to have
mom and dad at home and that sounds like
that's a good place it's not a it's not
a like uh
they're not a part of the problem right
and so then
in six months nine months you're gonna
look up this dog's gonna be fully grown
you're gonna be debt free
you can figure out the payment with you
and your parents on this thing maybe you
pay 10 grand of it they pay the other
six or something they're willing to help
you out
then you've saved up money now you're
working full-time you've got a
full full-time partner with this dog and
then you're ready to go get an apartment
you see what i'm saying
yeah and then
then you can just head right out right
yeah there's no yeah the urgency i don't
want you to have to feel right now
shannon because there is no urgency
you're i mean besides the dog and
getting that dog in september
but besides that all the other stuff
yeah i mean even if you paused and you
yeah you waited nine months if you
waited till next summer even if it was
12 months you said hey next may
my goal is to be on my own all of that i
think that there's no i think there'd be
more harm to the urgency of doing things
out of order versus just tapping the
brakes and you're good and to continue
to heal
but on a kind of a tactical side shannon
i would i would challenge you just on
what your job is i mean you're making
13.50 an hour
and there's a lot of places that are
paying 20 even up to 25 um maybe with
the skill set that you have and so
i would just you know even just in the
next week or two
just look look around and say okay is
there anything that can just up that
because even even getting a seven dollar
an hour raise is going to significantly
help you over the course of of these
months as you're saving up for the dog
and then um and again i don't put too
much on you but if you're trying to
think okay how much money how can i get
money as quickly as possible
for this big expense that's the dog
that's going to help me so much in life
um i've heard john so many so many
people doing things from home
yeah i mean like there's like i don't
know if there's a job that you can pick
up for like two hours in the evenings on
your computer and you can make just a
little bit more money there and and
again some of this feels like a drop in
the bucket when you're like 16 000
but over time do the math map it out and
say okay how what can i do in the short
term that's not going to just damage who
i am but really be able to
um
help in my healing and give me a little
bit of the confidence there's there'll
be a confidence boost a dignity that
you're gonna have shannon when you say
wow
i went and did this like i saved up this
and um all of it and the fact that your
parents are there willing to help you i
think is amazing and if they're able to
gift you any of that money toward the
dog you know and you can kind of figure
that out that's that's awesome too but
um but that tactically i would say
yes your thousand dollars um
emergency fund is is really key but this
dog is going to be like number one so
saving towards that
as soon as possible i think is huge good
for you proud of you it's awesome
shannon so so great
uh man i feel like we yeah on your line
of work seeing what kova did in the
shutdown like was did more more stuff
spiked right i mean everything that i've
seen with like whether it's depression
anxiety all of it yeah it seems like
there was a time when
that that we're still feeling the
effects right
i think we've got 100 year turn around
and not to be pessimistic but
um somebody asked me on an interview a
few a few months ago did i think this
was worse than the 9 11 tragedy
um and i said yes because after 9 11 we
had a common
thing we could point at they were trying
to get us and for this one what got
weaponized was each other oh and so
we've got to reconnect with one another
yes